hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so in this video guys i
want to tell you about a project that i
think is a really really cool it's a nft
crypto project that has just started
the reason why i make a video about that
is because uh this is the beginning of
this project and as you guys know there
are a lot of giveaways at the beginning
of this project because they are trying
to grow so i i don't know what this
project is going to be
in a few years but what i know is that
the team is very serious i know the
manager of this project is a friend of
mine that's coming from paris and when
he told me about all the giveaways they
have i said all right i need to share
that with my community so for those who
are interested into the nft and crypto
world this video is for you so let's get
into it
[Music]
all right guys so the project i wanted
to tell you about is called skylanders
it's basically a fantasy adventure game
where you can play and you know win
tokens and then the tokens can be
transferred in us dollars
so you know you have a lot of projects
in the nft and crypto world and you know
most of them let's be honest they
uh they're not serious projects because
they don't have any utility and i think
that this project is actually the future
because we are talking here about the
metaverse and you know there are they
give a lot of advantages to the
community so you can hear i'm going to
share with you the links guys but you
can see pretty much everything that can
happen in this project so
they're gonna be some airdrops game
advantages everything is gonna be voted
you can stack and but the interesting
thing so you can go through that and
read everything for those who are
interested you have here the white
papers so you can see this product is
pretty serious because you know a lot of
nft projects and i know a bit about that
because now as you guys know i'm in the
nft world as well i'm starting my own
project
and most of the nft projects don't have
a white paper here they have a white
paper so you can go through it and read
everything they explain how the game
will work how the tokens will be
possible to earn everything that you can
do you have the game white pepper as
well that is available so you can go
through that it's not that long
but the interesting thing is that they
are just starting and you know they're
gonna make a lot of giveaways it's very
easy to get these giveaways at the
beginning especially if you are in the
early birds on discord so to be in the
early birds i saw that somewhere okay
the first 1000 discord users will get
the early bird discord roll
it's very interesting because basically
the way it works is that they have
different roles as you can see a little
bit higher
you have the legendary epic rare early
bird and regular members so basically if
you arrive at the beginning you're going
to be early bird you need to be in the
first 1000 for now that's 700. so if you
arrive in the first 1000 members you can
become early bird for now they are at
700 which means that there are still 300
places available and basically for early
birds it's going to be much easier to
win the giveaways then you have
different roles and it's also much
easier when you arrive at the beginning
to get this rose and the uh advantage of
getting for example the legendary rose
is that you have 15 entries entries for
what for the giveaways and you can see
here they plan to for example give 50
busd a couple couple of times a week
they're going to have some role
giveaways you have here
45 epic roles so basically you can make
money you can win nfts because they're
going to have nfts basically the nfts
that they create is created by the
designer that is also designing the game
for now the game has not been built so
it's the project it's gonna maybe take a
few months maybe one or two years i
don't know but in the game you're gonna
have different equipment uh tools uh
guild items lands and those are the nfts
and the idea is to arrive early to get
the big roles and then to get the good
nfts ideally for free or for a very good
price and if the game is working well
and you arrived at the beginning which i
don't know i don't know how it's going
to go guys let's be honest it's a you
know very futuristic project there are a
lot of competition but once again i know
the team is serious and if they're doing
well then the nfts that you can get
almost for free at the beginning are
going to be worth a lot and you know i
think that this kind of game is
i mean this kind of project is really
the future because they allow you know
to create guild so you can see that here
you can read everything but the website
is pretty clear you have a lot of
information so here you can create guild
and basically play within a group and uh
win tokens in the game and as you guys
know this is very popular today there
are even some investors that are gonna
pay gamers to play in those games to
make money in the game tokens and then
trans convert these tokens into uh us
dollars so i think that you know nfts
are great but let's be honest once again
most of an ftp project there are you
know not real projects my project i'm
gonna develop it in a video whenever my
website is going to be ready i'm talking
here about the crypto bulls i'm sure you
guys saw that already
is
a useful project as well because we're
going to use the money to make crypto
arbitrage and generate profits for
investors this project is useful as well
because it's going to attract a lot of
investors that are going to pay for the
gamers to play in the game so i i don't
know if the play is going to be exciting
and well done or not i'm very sure that
we'll do the best to do that but what i
know is is that if they succeed this can
have big value and right now you can
have almost everything for free if you
go to the discord and you start to play
so i'm gonna share the links with you
okay but what i wanted to show you guys
is this so once again i'm gonna share
this link here if you follow that it's
very easy and if you follow them on
twitter you make 10 entries you retweet
30 entries i mean they're just just
distributing things for free at the
beginning to the community to grow which
is totally normal and this is the reason
why once again i want you to make this
video so for those who are interested
you have the opportunity for free and it
takes just a few seconds to get the
maximum of entries today go in the
discord play the games play the quizzes
just be there be active you know how it
works if you are interested into the nft
and crypto
projects and then you can have those
nfts almost for free you can make once
again you have here different uh levels
so the first level i think is going to
start has started maybe you you can go
and have a look it should be starting
mid april so we are 20 seconds i think
it has started so
15 busd twice a week here a lot of
giveaways you can make you can win some
rules once again everything here is
related to these rules if you have the
legendary role for sure it's going to be
very easy to get
the good nfts in the game at a very good
price so if you're interested into that
i mean i think that you know it just
takes a few seconds and i think it's a
very interesting project once again the
reason why i want you to share this
video is because it's for free guys so i
don't know if it's going to work let's
be honest but what i know is that for
now at the early stage of a project
there is no risk and it's maybe maybe a
hope because once again it's my friend
maybe they're going to moon and if they
do and you arrived at the beginning you
guys know that uh it can be very
profitable so what else can i tell you
about this project yeah so here you have
the white papers i'm gonna uh keep
updating you guys about what is
happening here once again john the
discord the discord is here as you can
see they have uh you know a lot of uh
reactions already and you know not a lot
of members only 700 once again up to
1000 you can become early bulls so it's
very interesting to get those giveaways
more easily so i'm gonna keep updating
you guys about how this product is going
and let me know in the comments if you
are interested for me to make more
videos like that because i think it's
interesting you know it's uh it's the
future you know so once again some
projects they're not gonna go uh you
know to the to the next step because
they're not serious project this project
is serious i know the team is serious
which doesn't mean that they will
succeed but at least they're gonna do
the best they can and they have good
partners and they are well connected to
the crypto and nft world uh and they're
gonna do their best to succeed so that's
it for today i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys